a woman accused of stealing a Las Vegas  hotel guest's watch and concealing it  inside her genitals on Sunday was in  town for a Monday court date for a  similar crime a man called 9-1-1 from  the Aria Hotel Sunday morning reporting  a woman later identified as 33-year-old  Sarah Richards had taken items from his  room including a twelve thousand dollar  watch officers say they met up with  Richards in the lobby and they say  that's when they found the watch  concealed inside her body Richards was  in town for a Monday court hearing  involving a case where police say she  stole another man's watch also at a  strip Hotel police say Richards lives in  Baltimore she posted bond in his due in  court again in January